for now though we're gonna play a little
would you rather and let's start with
the cincinnati bengals if you're the
bengals would you rather draft lsu's joe
burrow number one overall or trade down
and see what's behind door number two
with all of the other stuff you get on
top of it well yes um
i still think i'd deal with joe burrow i
i would from what i you know from what
we saw this year first off sec football
you don't see quarterbacks go off like
this very often i mean this is a special
special year this is a special special
talent this kid i mean he's got a real
good arm it's not like a patrick mahomes
arm or something like that but it's a
real good arm he really knows how to
play the position he's got a great feel
he's an incredible athlete
incredible
and i think for that you know you trade
down and this guy ends up being and
added to that he's an amazing
you know he's got all the things you
want as far as a communicator face of
the franchise the way he handles himself
all those things they'll be kicking
themselves if it's two years from now
and this kid's a star and they're gonna
go man we passed him up after he just
blew it up so i'd say draft joe burrow
it's the kyle murray theory a little bit
again exactly right right you don't want
to pass on the guy who becomes the next
big thing when you have the opportunity
to get a guy who's going to be a star
who's going to get people to come to
your games because right now look around
there aren't a lot of people there he's
going to sell jerseys he's going to
generate excitement he's going to make
the bengals relevant again if he's the
goods and it looks like he's the goods
all right wait wait wait wait you got to
give your answer there slugger that's my
answer that's my answer of course you
take him okay but but i i will allow for
the possibility the bengals will screw
this one up that that will be part of
the drama in the run-up to the draft
will they screw it up will the panthers
or some other team make the bengals an
offer that they don't refuse all right
next up if you're a vikings fan would
you rather see
which of the following get an extension
kirk cousins or dalvin cook or mike
zimmer or any combination of the three
well it's it's like to me it's between
dalvin cook and mike zimmer i mean those
are the two that i'm worried about i
mean you said what you want mike
zimmer's done an unbelievable job with
the vikings ever since he's been there i
mean your squad has been relevant ever
since he's been there yeah and of course
in the final late you know been in the
wild card in the final four they've done
a lot of great things but i guess if you
made me just narrow it down to one
between zimmer and cook i'm gonna go
with cook i mean cook a special as we
saw i mean he was definitely the guy
responsible for the offense being what
it was this year and if he was good the
offense was good if the run game
couldn't get going it wasn't but he's
one of the best running backs in
football we know that so i go cook
but here's the thing what if you extend
cook and the next coach decides he's not
going to run the ball the way that they
did
with zimmer and kubiak and cook mashing
it into the line of scrimmage i here's
here's what i would do and this came up
yesterday on the pft pm podcast i talked
about it earlier on the radio hour i had
an epiphany yesterday trying to figure
out what the vikings should do i think
they should just tell all of them we're
not giving out any new contracts you
have to go this year and get it you have
to earn it and if you do you'll get a
contract on the back end but the vikings
right now are in that category of good
to pretty good but they're not dominant
yeah and i feel like this formula on
offense is not going to get them where
they want to be chris it'll get them to
ten and six sure nine and seven eleven
and five it's not going to get them to
the category of first overall seed
dominant team kicking butt in the
postseason it's not going to get there
give give them every reason give them a
carrot and a stick for 2020. and if they
get it done fine you keep it going if
they don't then it's easier to move on
what if you give all these guys
extensions
and then you realize what what's getting
i don't know you know i mean is this
year if they have the same results as
this year is that getting it done i mean
that's i don't think that's good enough
i don't think that's good enough i think
that this spinning your wheels in that
category of somewhere between 8 and 15
in the nfl i don't think that's good
enough and i think it's problematic
because the longer you're in that that
territory the more impatient ownership
is gonna get and if you have to do a
rebuild i guess my point is this
i i don't want them to give into the
temptation to kick the can
extend all these guys and then realize a
year or two from now it's just not
working and we need to rip the band-aid
off and start over i'd rather them do it
after the 2020 season if we if they have
in minnesota another year like they had
this season i i just think that that the
wolf's have every right to say to all of
those guys no extensions with the jury's
out on whether or not we want to
continue this beyond 2020. and they're
big boys they should be able to deal
with it right hey derrick henry doesn't
have a contract beyond this postseason
ryan tannehill doesn't have a contract
beyond this postseason is it causing
them to play well or play poorly yeah
well i mean i i understand that i mean i
know what you're saying i'm just saying
dalvin cook was the best player on their
offense one of the best players you know
in general in the offense in offense all
together in football this year and even
if you did change offensive coordinators
or schemes dalvin cook's talent is the
kind that's going to translate to any
offense really it doesn't matter i mean
get the guy in space and watch out any
any offensive coordinator is going to
love that so i mean i i hear your points
there but dalvin cooks within every
writer to also sit here and go you know
what i was you know arguably the best
running back in the game last year i'm
going to sit my butt out it's running
back he's already torn acl once you know
so i i would say if anything you sign
him he's not the guy i think i would
penny pinch on if you're gonna start to
penny pinch hey xavier rhodes see you
later hey everson griffin that's a
formula version yeah
that's a no-brainer yeah that's a
no-brainer these are core guys though
and and remember you and i were both at
the front of the line last year saying
hey
zeke pay zeke what did the cowboys get
out of zeke after they paid it yeah no
not what they should have that's for
sure you're right that so but you didn't
pick one either so stop making me answer
none of the above okay none of them okay
off the three though if i had to take
one and that's the way it's framed
cousins or cook or zimmer
i'd probably go zimmer i'd probably go
zimmer but i would want uh him to buy
into the notion that they need to be
making plans for an offense that
involves a quarterback that can do
something when the running game isn't
there and when the protection breaks
down because kirk cousins and vikings
fans get mad about this i mean folks use
your eyes
he can do nothing when the running game
isn't there and when the protection
breaks down he just crumbles that's it
there are quarterbacks who know how to
extend a play they do it horizontally
they take off running the ball or they
step up into the pocket they slide
around or they know who the ball is
going to before they even get in their
hands and the ball's out before the
pocket collapses they need a quarterback
who can move like the young quarterbacks
who are doing so well and who can
process information shut up and pick one
what did you pick if you're this i'm i i
said that sorry
i got it guys so you shut up okay well
if you're the saints would you rather
give drew brees one last crack at it by
the way happy birthday drew he's 41
today would you hand the keys to taysom
hill
whoa
this is a tough one if this really is
there's no not for me
i would hand the keys to taysom hill i
would i you know again hey
drew brees does some really good things
there's no doubt about that
can you know i don't know i question
whether drew bree you know drew brees
can he win you games deep in the
playoffs anymore i don't know about that
either you know i don't hey the rams
game a few years ago in the nfc
championship game that should have been
21-0 instead they let the rams hang
around you know there's the issues of
throwing the ball deep hey they lost all
their games this year drew brees was the
starter not teddy bridgewater i think
taysom hill brings an interesting skill
set the team set up to be able to be
successful around him you know he showed
me enough with his throwing not only in
the regular season but what he did in
the preseason that that's gone to
starting quarterback level type of
throws uh so this is a really close one
but yes i do think i go taysom hill
yeah i think i go taysom hill and it's
not that close for me i think that a lot
of what we've seen from drew brees the
past couple years is the product of sean
payton even though he has still
generated phenomenal statistics his
passer rating for 2019 the highest of
his career he had that night for the
ages against the colts but look you
can't keep both you can't if you pay
brees on top of the dead money they're
carrying 21.3 million from past
contracts there's no way you're going to
be able to match an offer sheet that
comes in for taysom hill now in that
case the best case scenario you get a
first round pick for taysom hill but i
think there are multiple teams maybe
teams that would be percolating down at
the bottom of the draft so it's not that
big of a first round pick that you're
getting that will come in and make an
offer that you won't be able to match on
taysom hill when sean payton says the
guy's steve young i don't think he's
playing the okie doke on definitely i
think he means it yes and he was the
best player on the field in that game
against the vikings a week and a half
ago so i'd go take some hill especially
with sean payton there to get the most
out of him yes i agree i you know i
agree and you you know you you said it
better than i did also you know hey yes
it was great completion percentage great
quarterback rating all that the saints
weren't dangerous on offense they're not
dangerous i would rather him be less of
a completion percentage and less of a
quarterback rating and more dangerous
you know and that's the issue we've seen
when teams start to take away the five
all the plays you talked about the sean
payton plays when you take those away
where sean payton can't get michael
thomas wide open over the middle or
alvin kamara wide open coming out of the
backfield the offense it hurts and
that's what's happened to him in all
their losses or any of their big playoff
games those completions are taken away
and then drew brees is just not going to
beat you with his right arm right now
i'm sorry that's just the way it is and
he's still really good and can do a lot
of good but he can't carry the team and
i don't know if he can get him over the
hump to get him to the super bowl and
win that game
a very wise man once told me that the
healthy tension between coach and
franchise quarterback is the competition
with the coach coming up with easy
touchdown passes easy first downs in the
play that's drawn up and the quarterback
making something out of nothing on the
fly sure that's how they one-up each
other and i really do think that over
the past couple of years in new orleans
it's been skewed far more toward what
sean payton draws up not drew brees
making something out of nothing case in
point what happened when michael thomas
ran the wrong route in that vikings yeah
exactly
right right yeah i think that's a real
point
all right last one
if you only get one this weekend who
would you rather see with the ball down
two down by four points with two minutes
left and 75 yards to go for the birth in
the super bowl aaron rodgers of the
packers or your homie and my homie
patrick mahomey gosh so we're just
saying who we would rather see it's not
like who we think is better here which
guy which guy if you who would you
rather see who would you rather want to
watch with the ball on their own 25 down
four two minutes left your guy rogers or
our guy mahomes gosh i mean
this is like who would i rather see i
mean of course i love watching both of
these guys
um
i guess right now for this moment i'd
rather see aaron rodgers just because i
feel like there's going to be more
pressure on him now right i think
mahomes might be and this is yeah and
we're going to see my homes for the next
15 years that's what i mean exactly
right yes so when you just say you who
would you rather i'm going with rogers
yes because of the magnitude of the
career and everything that could all be
enhanced with him going to another super
bowl lefleur first year head coach all
of those things going into it uh yes i
guess i i would rather go with aaron
rodgers
yeah we're gonna be spoiled by patrick
mahomes for the next generation or maybe
close to it for aaron rodgers and his
appreciation of the fact that he's
getting closer and closer to the end
peter king noticed when he was at
lambeau field on sunday a different
attitude from aaron rodgers because he
understands that that every spin is one
spin closer to no more spins for aaron
rodgers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports